Chad it's lovely to see you here today
at collector mania how you been enjoying
it
oh it's been nothing but a love fest you
know the people love the show and it's
just no real warm and fuzzy so it's
pretty cool to hear that
now of course so many people are such
huge fans at the walking-dead what was
it like being part of that show being
part of that family as it were yeah our
family is absolutely true you know it's
a very authentic group of people who
generally are very passionate about the
work and very funny and very intelligent
people she's hanging with the cool kids
well your favorite kind of memories from
it your favorite scenes when you're
shooting the show yeah you know my
favorite memories are I would say the
profit of the darker moments have to
show because I think that's when we were
able to push the envelope you know and
tell stories like The Grove with Lizzie
and mica were able to pull that off have
people stay attached to the humanity as
opposed to just the McCobb nature of it
or some kind of shock value I felt we
were able to do the same thing with my
death scene so you know those two I
think are the true I remember for
somewhat selfish reasons it's not
because I was in now now that was
amazing I don't know it was amazing
storytelling though you know I think
those shows are the times we took the
most risk
how were you of the comics which
obviously a very popular and Teresa's
very popular character in the comics as
well before you took on the part in the
show I knew nothing about it
I honestly all I knew there was this
poster with a guy standing on something
with a big gun my my agent said they
were excited when I was approached about
it by Robert Kirkland who was a creative
graphic novel it was very much
interested in me playing the role
because he saw me on the HBO series The
Wire
and so after that I did my homework and
then I I was incredibly excited as well
and wanted to be a part of this
juggernaut what did you kind of take
from the comic books after you kind of
see did your homework and what do you
feel like you brought to tyrese the TV
tyrese I brought another level of
complexity to to Tyrese he was much more
torn about violence and you know Daryl
was not a part of the comic so Daryl
became bricks right-hand man so he we
had to do something different with
Tyreese and so I just thought I thought
I'm a much more multi-layered type of
guy that that people I think rooted for
in a different way than they did in the
comander Lee of course oh you're dying
scene so what was it like filming those
I mean what kind of emotions were there
how was it like behind the scenes well
it was incredibly intense which I love I
mean that's what I do you know we we run
into the burning building of emotion
where most people don't want to feel
that stuff where I'll feel it for you so
that was amazing it's amazing and
challenging you know everybody knows the
motion scenes are incredibly challenging
and probably a dissent don't pull it off
so you know but for me it's like let's
go let's let's go there and you have
david morrissey come back and you know
was just you know just an extra added
cherry on the top you know david
morrissey coming back I mean we had
quite a few people coming back during
those things didn't we I mean do you
think that's something that could happen
in the future maybe for Tyrese for other
characters you know I don't know that
they're gonna you know they're always
making sure to stay authentic with not
overwork a storyline or or a certain
approach that they use and storytelling
so they'll probably find some kind of
unique way for me to come back
that'd be interesting but there's no
guarantees of course now we've also got
the pre-cool show haven't we fear The
Walking Dead I mean what do you think
about that and how likely do you think
we would be to see maybe Tyrese on that
again as well no there's no
cross-pollination this is the prequel
and they don't want to compare they
compress time too much then they bring
us in the same world so that world is
gonna take its time and unfold and tell
itself you know maybe around what
episode I'm in season five for them if
they continue you know they're gonna
take their time whether they're gonna
wring it for everything is work so they
don't want to do that you know they
don't want to attach us too much but I'm
curious I have no idea this is the first
kind of full ray into a spinoff from the
show you know what happens sometimes in
television history when you go with a
spinoff but I think there's room for it
you know and and I think we got the
right people helming it so we'll see I'm
curious I want to see what's what it's
like cause you always thought arias or
this hammer didn't wait I mean if you
had to pick your weapon of choice for a
zombie apocalypse forward it very
horrible question a hammer is an amazing
piece of equipment that never fails you
know as long as you can keep a hold on
the thing and you got a pretty good
swing you don't have to be that strong
that's you know amazing piece of steel
well I would stick with that or a knife
you know pragmatic you know of course
you've seen recently one of your former
Walking Dead colleagues John Burns all's
been cast in season two of daredevil
Marvel's big superhero show so I was
wondering would you be interested in a
kind of superhero supervillain show
whether it's one of those kind of dark
and gritty or ones like daredevil or one
of the lights are kind of more comedic
Marvel ones that those out there what
would you think about that I would think
I would want to go I like the dark you
know it's just just you can go with so
many different levels when you're
dealing in that kind
area so you know I mean we're working on
our own deal called tread water and if
we go to tread water dot TV you'll see
what's going on we're creating something
new and I'm an amazing role to play in
that so check that out and see where
we're trying to go a little bit more
about tread water it's it's it's trans
media franchise and it's a we got the
graphic novel that's really gonna launch
and comic book stores across the country
in July I'm gonna have a major push with
that we're developing a television show
it's a you know it's a motion comic it's
an interactive web series so you know
any way you want it that's the way we're
gonna give it to you and it's it's not
15 years into the future the euro is
crashed the world is dark and edgy every
country for itself so the government
hires a private group that once the
media gets wind of them because they're
missed this mysterious group of people
that call tread water but they're trying
to keep the world safe from terrorism a
nuclear threat and all sorts of things
that are kind of emanating from what's
going on in the world right now so I
think that's going to be really really
interesting I mean how would you
characterize it in terms of genre if
somebody asks you where would it fit in
terms of current TV shows or current
comic books it's it's it's it's dark
like Batman it's the storytelling it's
like loss where you have all these
elaborate backstories and then it has
the whole terrorism and espionage of
homeland so you got those kind of
convinced you're putting those kind of
conventions together and tells a little
bit about your character in it oh yeah
mr. OC is he's a bad boy you know
he's an arms dealer and he's he sells
Intel and he sells arms to the highest
bidder very rich man very business
oriented but if you cross him you see a
darker side and he's lost a limb for a
particular reason that you're see later
on and he has this kind of robotic arm
inside of this briefcase so he places
his hand in this briefcase he can morph
it into any type of weapon that he wants
so that's pretty kick-ass yeah you know
it's exciting and whereabouts is it is
it's at the show oh it's in this it's
it's international it's all yeah it's
it's it's just as it should be the world
you know where we are now
you're in the States you're in Europe
you're in the Middle East could be
anywhere because the threat could come
from anywhere and you mentioned of
course is a graphic the graphic novels
and this movie shows well how's it gonna
work is it gonna be we're gonna see
comic you know the graphic novels first
and then a TV show or yeah we're pushing
we're gonna use the graphic novel as the
wedge but you know if we get more
attractions for the video game where we
get more attraction for the television
show they all each serves the other the
popularity of one is only going to
increase enough to popularity level of
another so we're going to use the the
graphic novel as the wedge does remind
us again where people can find out more
about it oh yeah tread water TV or at
tread water for Twitter and Instagram
and is there anything else we can look
forward to coming up from you chairs
well I have another show called the
expanse with Thomas Jane and that's
going to come out on the sci-fi Network
in December and yeah it's a spaceship
drama we don't
one of those now and that's like a
hundred and fifty years in the future
and and we're on Mars and Earth and
everywhere else in the stratosphere so
that's going to be an amazing show for
sure what's your character in that Oh
Fred Lucius Johnson is a commander and
he's fine himself in between a rock and
a hard place working for the government
but that's problematic and so he's got
some things he's got to do that the
government is not aware of what he's up
to but it's going to be pretty cool and
we're gonna be able to see the expense
it's massively on the sci-fi Network
starting in December
ladies it's good stuff coming up future
I can't wait to see it all and lots of
luck with Fred waters well it sounds
like an intriguing project oh yeah it's
amazing undertaking we're excited about
it and then the you know the groundswell
is happening now and people are very
very inquisitive about it and you know
it's a bold leap you know not too many
people are able to break through and all
those genres so that's what we're after
look forward to finding out more in the
future thanks Chad thank you thank you
you